[Musique]
là je vais regarder mes messages sur tik
tok et je vais répondre à des abonnés
donc on va leur répondre en faisant des
gâteaux en fait les gens me demandent de
leur répondre en mangeant un rouleau de
papier toilette une pizza une brosse à
chiottes aussi mais là il faut kaka bon
ça c'est drôle ça les fait rire en fait
ils aiment tout ce qui est un peu dégueu
alors là j'ai préparé des biscuits au
cacao que j'ai recouvert de crème au
caramel au beurre salé et on va les
recouvrir pour faire un cheeseburger
j'ai adoré défier il faut juste du temps
c'est tout je me suis fait remarquer sur
les réseaux sociaux en faisant des
modelages de princesses disney donc j'ai
commencé à faire des tutos après j'étais
invité dans des salons pour donner des
cours faire des démonstrations
moi j'avais été vachement impressionné
par la colle du cycle style jeunes ah
oui c'est vrai mais ça c'est vrai
qu'elle a plu l'accueil y en a même qui
m'ont dit mais c'était une bricole mais
souvent je suis traité trois langues
mais c'est vrai après ça me fait rire je
le cherche un petit peu en ses buts
toujours aimé créé en fait et tu as fait
une formation particulière non lequel
faisait du tout du tout du tout jamais
araxxe est autodidacte voilà chez
autodidacte en fait je regarde je
reproduis après la chance qu'on a aussi
c'est qu'il ya des vidéos sur internet
c'est beaucoup les américains en fait
qu'ils font ça donc je me suis j'ai en
fait on va dire que j'ai appris les
bases grâce à internet les premiers
temps c'était l'incertitude
ça fait un an pendant un an ou va durer
deux trois mois je suis content parce
que pour l'instant je dis bien pour
l'instant je n'ai pas de waters donc
j'ai une trop bonne communauté qui à
fond dans mon délire donc c'est même eux
kim sosa a trouvé des trompe-l'oeil pour
faire des prouesses et c'est ça que
j'adore
on va je crois qu'on va laisser comme ça
il veut que crachoter donc je sais pas
s'il existe ce burger avec des petits
points mais bon il aura inventé c'est
quoi la demande n'a plus
alors la torche 1 c'est la serviette
hygiénique usagers qui mais j'ose pas la
faire parce que je me dis j'ai peur que
ça reste quoi je vais être la nana qui a
mangé une stricte si génique
du coup je n'ose pas
j'arrive à émerveiller des personnes
avec des choses pour moi qui sont pas
spectaculaires
donc
c'est ce qui est fait que je resterai
aujourd'hui
c'est quoi la vidéo qui t'a fait percer
les échanges comme estime quand je
mangeais ce fameux gâteaux en forme des
ponts jeu les gens pensaient que j'avais
mal a dit que je mangeais des objets
j'avais que des commentaires comme ça
mais continue à jouer le jeu avec ce
qu'ils avaient compris en réalisant
d'autres trompe l'oeil aujourd'hui vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux à me
demander de réaliser des auteurs
j'avais mis de du liquide vaisselle qui
étaient dues de la gelée de framboises
que j'avais war jolis pieds de framboise
et jany de la mousse blanche comme si
c'était du savon et du coup elle est
choquant c'est que je mangeais vraiment
du liquide vaisselle sur une éponge avec
la mousse bon je vais poser on va faire
le papier ouais allez hop alors ça ça
intéresse tout le monde parce que
j'étais un ticket de caisse d'ailleurs
c'est un fait le buzz et les gens
pensent que je mange du vrai papier donc
pour ceux qui croient que c'est à vous
c'est faux c'est un prêt papier
cheeseburger au qu'on va le mettre dans
le scanner
alors ça c'est une imprimante
alimentaire dans cette pratique pour
faire les étiquettes et tout ça
[Musique]
ça tombe bien parce que c'est la pause
déjeuner et j'avais envie de manger un
cheeseburger
regardez le cheeseburger que je vais
manger je vais me régaler d'abord je
vais manger le papier
j'adore je vais croque à pleines dents
il est trop beau
[Musique]